so my first question is probably the
most important question how is miles oh
I was hoping you would ask that because
he had this really really important to
check up yesterday yep it was his
two-year checkup since his chemo ended
and they checked all about all the
cancer but also about his learning
functions and basically every every
function you can have and his mom wrote
happy dance smiley face and so it was a
great appointment and he's all checked
out and that's really he was in
remission this whole you know for the
last two years but that was I was
holding my breath and have you seen him
since the film oh yeah we see him well
he lives like seven hours right so it's
kind of a as he most is he kept the
Batman walk the batkid whoa no no he
only does that if he's fully fully in
the garb he doesn't if he's wearing one
piece he doesn't do it um no he'll only
do it with EJ okay yeah I want to talk
about the making of the film itself but
I want to start by talking about
charitable giving in the United States
because this watching this movie made me
wonder what the trend was and I looked
it up according to giving us a 2014 was
the all-time record in the United States
for charitable giving 358 point four
billion dollars which was up from 340
billion in 2013 these are
inflation-adjusted dollars so this is
apples to apples and it broke the record
set in 2007 so in working on this film
and seeing what happens when people get
activated motivated to give what is your
take about how social media is playing
into this accelerating generosity within
the United States for charity Kurt I'm
I'm honestly not sure as with with the
event itself and the film it's one of
those things that I think it's really
kind of hard to know because you start
seeing an aggregate response of everyone
but it's hard to know what all those
little pieces are per se because there's
so many of them so i'm i'm honestly not
sure vonage you have some theories I
mean I would just think that it's it's
just not to say i live in silicon valley
so i want to sound all silicon valley
ish but but it really just amplifies a
cool
sage so something like that kid not that
it was film I mean people didn't give
money to that event but it certainly got
the word out about make a wish so I
think it just takes something that's
cool and can blow it up and so I think
you saw that with the ice bucket
challenge the ice bucket challenge and
and other things like that and the the
koni koni 2012 was it and so I think
it's really like just an awesome force
and I think that you know there's so
much negativity around social media and
Twitter in particular less so I think
Facebook but I think it's amazing to
have stuff things that can happen that
that can propel a movement forward and
you see it you know with the revolutions
and other things now one of the most
amazing things about the making of this
film is that neither of you was there at
the time is that correct yes so this is
some great reverse engineering where any
of you were either of you aware of it I
was not III was but she was not so what
happened how did you hear about it and
how did you kind of go back in time and
create a movie that made it look like
you were there it's so embarrassing uh
you know we talking to Phil about the
two billion people who watched it and I
was not one of the two billion people um
but I was editing that week on another
project and I was I guess I wasn't on
social media at all that week and I just
missed the whole thing and then some
colleagues and I were talking about it
than my kids who at the time were like
all under seven years old they started
talking about it and I was looking for a
project to do with my that my kids would
enjoy and like to participate in and and
so I thought to myself what a great
documentary that would have been you
know the person who's doing that is
super lucky and I kind of forgot about
it and I think we all have lots of
projects that you see in your like that
would've been really cool then a couple
weeks later one of my old colleagues
from NBC she we were chatting I said
what stories are you working on she goes
oh I'm trying to get an interview with
the batkid I said oh that would have
been such a great documentary she's like
oh I'm gonna call them when we hang up
to let me see if they'll meet with us
about a documentary and I was like sure
she calls back five minutes later she's
like oh I can't they're not doing
interviews anymore but we can talk we
can go in tomorrow morning at 9am for an
interview about a documentary so with
the make-a-wish group yep so we went in
and we had a two-and-a-half-hour me
with them and Patricia is very exciting
to talk to us clear on the phone and I
really the main question I asked her was
what did you intend to happen and when
she said she and she was hoping for 200
people to show up and I had since done
research and knew what had happened that
to me was just once I knew that was the
nugget that I wanted to go on that 200
people turned into 25,000 this is how
far after the event that is about three
weeks three weeks so it's very fresh and
her mom yes they were I think they had
almost been like catatonic for at least
like 10 days after it so I think it was
the perfect time because I think before
actually I think three or four other
crews had approached them but they could
they just couldn't deal with it
obviously I mean it was too much so I
think I was just the luckiest person in
the planet to get that because I think
even maybe a few months after they
wouldn't have done it either you notice
I kind of wanted to move on so it was
perfect timing so you have this meeting
they're interested in a documentary
you're available you're looking for
something to make for your kids given if
you know her past work not terribly
kid-friendly child molestation terror
household chemicals very serious things
but not the kind of things you want to
cuddle up with your kids and watch so
the timing is right professionally at
what point do you say did you film any
of this it was the very last question so
going into the meeting I knew I
obviously missed it but I was like okay
it was one of the biggest social media
phenomenons ever so on a lot of people
maybe we can crowdsource the video for
this even though I knew that would have
been a technical disaster to do
documentaries are always hard enough to
do with the most pristine of footage so
you know I was like okay we can do that
if worse comes to worse but the last
question I asked at the two after the
two and a half hour meeting house like
he didn't happen to shoot any of it did
you I was expecting like a little
handycam they're like oh yeah we wanted
a video for our for our fundraiser
coming up so we had a guy with five
camera I was like wait we don't even use
five cameras so so yes they had somebody
shooting it to make a video for them to
hope to bring in money at their gala and
we spoke with him i was able to license
get that footage and then also when the
between the 29th of october and the 15th
when it happened
it was going viral they the city and
Make A Wish realized that not everybody
would be able to see all that was
happening most people would show up at
City Hall at the end of the day so
comcast has a sports station in San
Francisco and they were so kind and they
they donated a crew for the day to shoot
all the capers and then quickly go back
to their trucks and edit them so that
they could put together something and
then the city got a Jumbotron that was
part of the hundred thousand dollars
that they spent and so they had an
edited package so everybody could see
what happened throughout the day so then
we were able to get that footage which
was amazing footage especially of the
crowds they had a lot of footage so we
got that footage and those were the bulk
of everything but then the thing that
really I think saved us was the family
the Scots had been given a present of a
video camera as they were leaving town
they had never shot any video before and
on their way out of town somebody gave
them a video camera and they shot the
circus Center where there were no
cameras and they shot some of me I mean
they're you know usually when you get
footage from people you're like you know
you don't have high hopes for what it
isn't remember the morning it was like
five in the morning i was i was up
clicking through their things i'm like
these are amazing and the circus center
that had shot some of the video to
themselves they lost their footage so
that was gone lost us and just erased it
deleted it weichert he was like wait
what do you mean they lost I'm like hurt
people lose lose media they don't not
things you need of it so Kurt when did
you come into the project you coming
were you at this meeting as well no no
um in fact I had you know until june
twenty ninth of last year i had no idea
this was going to be entering my life i
was working on other things and she had
two different editors fall out in her we
know each other from the film festival
circuit and whatnot and she called me up
and said i need somebody had at this
movie and I'm supposed to have it done
in like three months for the sundance
deadline is there any way that's
possible and I thought well three months
is very fast for a first cut but let's
see then she had 50 hours I think of
material at the time it kept shooting
well we were we were cutting keeping
secrets I was shooting but wasn't like I
found the uber driver and in the
meanwhile and and the mayor agreed to do
it but I wouldn't tell him said it would
give him a heart attack so that I'd be
like when I thought he was going to move
it I'd be like here's some more
so yeah and i think i gave her a heart
attack as i said okay i want to watch
every frame of everything before I start
cutting it would Chevy fame which which
because that's because I said different
things are going to occur to you than I
could write me and I want you so it was
seven days a week before in the morning
making the makin my first cut was
actually two minutes shorter than this I
have a tendency the trim tighter and I
paste things very fast and she was like
okay let's split it breathe a little bit
more I'm like okay well how did you I
mean obviously there's a there is a
chronological thread to the story but as
filmmakers who have worked in narrative
him as well how did you see the axe
breaking down and how did you see the
dramatic structure of the film at odds
or playing against the chronological
nature of it well for me I when I first
looked at the footage or even was
thinking about what is this movie going
to be I thought two things one it's a
Frank Capra movie with real people it's
it's a wonderful life in real life and
two it's a buddy movie you know because
you meet you know little miles you meet
EJ and then you track them separately
for the first half they meet the night
before in this magical you know
superhero training camp and then they go
on this adventure together and the whole
movie at that point is a journey to the
line that EJ has at the end of the film
which is when he says it's like I have a
new little brother now and so there's
that but there's also an aspect to the
movie where it's kind of a heist film
too it's like the first half is the is
the planning and the second half is the
execution and knocking them down right
so those were kind of the genre boxes I
put it in in my head when I was putting
it together I can't speak for for Davis
approach but that was that was how I
thought of it